and welcome to Hannity We Begin tonight
with a Fox News Alert police body cam
footage showing the attack against Nancy
Pelosi's husband Paul will be released
we expect at any moment now thanks to a
ruling from a California judge as soon
as this video becomes available we of
course will show it to you right here on
this program also stay tuned tonight the
great one Mark Levin will be with us we
have the Hannity hot seat last call
tonight a liberal socialist I call my
radio show today got very interesting
we'll see what grade we get but first we
begin tonight on Capitol Hill where two
middle-aged men from California are
literally throwing a temper tantrum you
got Eric swalwell and Adam Schiff the
congenital liar likely still quivering
with rage after learning that their
relationship and their membership to the
all-powerful house intelligence
committee is no more house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy removed them from this
committee and for good reason according
to reports Congressman swalwell well
remember he was once a patsy he for the
Chinese government after getting seduced
by a woman named Fang Fang you can't
even make this up in a novel an
undercover agent for the Communist Party
of China unfortunately this was not a
one-night stand apparently a full-blown
relationship in fact there are the two
lovebirds right there together for quite
some time and the Chinese spy even
helped Eric raise money for his
re-election Adam the congenital liar
shift well meanwhile he didn't manage to
have any special relations with any
Chinese spies who can blame them but he
was duped by a Putin link Russian radio
show remember during that recorded phone
call with the Russian pranksters Adam
Schiff absolutely giddy so we wanted to
hear all about the compromising
materials uh pictures and then naked
Trump naked to them and as you can see
Schiff and small well they're easily
duped but they are also notorious Liars
in a big way now perhaps no one pushed
the Russia hoax more than these two con
men now to this day swalwell's
Congressional website is littered with
confusing charts and videos uh and
straight ahead from a fever dream
purportedly connecting dots on all that
trump-russia collusion that never
happened meanwhile for years Adam Schiff
he booked himself pretty much on every
fake news show that would have him he
told the world that the president of the
United States then Donald Trump was
colluding with Russia and ship promised
that he personally saw direct evidence
of this collusion that never happened
including ample evidence and plain sight
evidence that was more than
circumstantial both men claim they had
special access to this evidence because
of their membership on the house Intel
committee they were flat out lying no
evidence at all of trump-russia
collusion it didn't exist it never
happened no one in their right mind
should ever want these two lying idiots
anywhere near America's top secrets well
don't take my word for it let's just
listen to speaker McCarthy his powerful
beat down to a clueless PBS reporter
look at this you just told us
to ship in my allowing shift to be on
other committees
go right ahead thank you you said that
lying to us is something that means you
should be removed but why is it not a
fact
well let me be very this is
he's got elected by
his district so
okay let me be very clear and respectful
to you you asked me a question when I
answer it it's the answer to your
question you don't get to determine
whether I answer your question or not
okay in all respect thank you no no
let's answer her question
you just raised the question I'm gonna
be very clear with you the Intel
committee is different you know why
because what happens in the Intel
committee you don't know what happens in
the Intel committee although the secrets
are going on in the world
other members of Congress don't know
what did Adam Schiff do as the chairman
of the Intel committee what Adam Schiff
did use his power as a chairman and lie
to the American public even the
Inspector General said it but I will not
be like Democrats and play politics with
Thief where they removed Republicans
from committees and all committees so
yes he can serve on a committee but he
will not serve on Intel because it goes
to the National Security of America and
I will always put them first all right
and if you want to talk about swalwell
let's talk about swallow because you
have not had the briefing that I had I
had the briefing in Nancy Pelosi had the
briefing from the FBI the FBI never came
before this Congress to tell the
leadership of this Congress that Eric
swalwell had a problem with the Chinese
spy until he served on Intel so it
wasn't just us who were concerned about
the FBI was concerned about putting a
member of Congress on the Intel
committee that has the rights to see
things that others don't because of his
knowledge and relationship with the
Chinese spot but you know what those
voters elected shift even though he lied
those voters elected swallow even though
he lied to the American public too so
you know what I'll respect his voters
too and they'll serve on committees but
they will not serve on a place that has
National Security remnants because
Integrity matters to me that's the
answer to your question all right oos
that's how to that's how to battle a
corrupt media mob now needless to say
shift and swallow or not happy that they
have been exposed in fact swallow wants
you to believe that McCarthy's words are
putting his life at risk and Chip thinks
that Congress has been degraded take a
look
hypocrisy is probably the least of Mr
McCarthy's sins
um the most significant impact is that
he is continuing this destructive Trend
uh set by his party leader of tearing
down our institutions of degrading the
Congress this is purely about political
Vengeance the cost is not only removing
us from the committee on the
intelligence committee the cost is not
only breaking shattering the most
precious glassware in the cabinet a
committee that's always been bipartisan
the costs
are the death threats that Miss Omar
myself
and Mr Schiff keep getting because Mr
McCarthy continues to aim and project
these smears against us even though we
have said publicly
these smears are bringing death threats
he continues to do it which makes us
believe that there's an intent behind it
all right so where is the breathless
hysteria in the last Congress when
Democrats removed Marjorie Taylor Greene
and Paul goes her from every committee
because of some objectionable social
media posts for those death threats too
those nice emails texts that my staff
gets about me would they be considered
um death threats I might consider they
might be anyway where was the hysteria
when Nancy Pelosi blocked Jim Jordan and
Jim Banks from serving on the January
6th committee where was that outrage
where was the hysteria when Pelosi
called Republicans racist enemies of the
state who are coming for your children
don't believe me take a look they're
coming after your children protect your
children from what they're trying to do
it is absolutely essential for our
democracy that we win I fear for our
democracy and the Republicans forever to
get the gamble I don't paint all of
those very wealthy people as racist anti
nights and whatever
trumpian but that's how they vote
Millions hundreds of thousands of people
will die if this bill passes and sadly
the domestic enemies to our voting
system and are honoring our constitution
uh are right at 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
with their allies in the Congress of the
United States it's really actually
shameful enemies of the state
maybe Nancy pelosio to bring in The
Exorcist that she brought into her house
all over Washington D.C obviously none
of this bothers Eric's Falwell because
it's not directed him the small-minded
narcissistic congressman from California
really only cares about his own feelings
so please be kind to him during this
very trying time he's triggered and keep
in mind shift and swallow are more than
welcome to join another committee so is
Squad member uh Omar who is also in
Jeopardy of losing her assignment on the
Foreign Affairs committee many want Omar
removed rightly so because there were
past anti-semitic remarks including that
tweet right there Israel has hypnotized
the world may Allah awaken the people
and help them see the evil doings of
Israel now Democrats actually backed a
resolution condemning her history of
anti-Semitism but now they're bashing
Republicans for daring to remove her
from the Foreign Affairs committee not a
committee she should be on if Democrats
Wanted full control over their members
committees assignments well they
shouldn't have ban Republicans from
committees during the last Congress they
sent the president the president now
they want to whine and complain and cry
and act like a victim pretty disgusting
time to grow up spare the country the
drama instead maybe send McCarthy a
thank you note for keeping our country
safe by removing these two morons from
the Intel committee hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else